welcome to this video playing a vest
failure westfalia not I have played this
guy before which is surprising I cannot
remember this guy has four thousand five
minute games and I've played him only
four times amazing okay ah i started
with e4 but i'm not particularly unhappy
about transposing into this kind of
opening the king's indian i wanted to to
try the protrusion system again oh okay
it was recently played back ramnik in
the london chess classics to beat
nakamura very convincingly of course the
petrossian system is not the refusin a
reputation of the Kings Indian I mean
that no system is but I was thinking
it's maybe worth looking at again the
protrusion system was a mainstay of
chrome legs repertoire for quite a long
time and of course he then switched it
to the bionet attack but still what is
he doing here rupee 8 you're never going
to play f5 is what you're saying okay
maybe I should have just played like
normal stuff I mean like on the
queenside I mean this is not bad but
still it's not really necessary to play
on the King side once he plays rookie 80
basically we have relinquishes all ideas
of a quick attack on the King side but
ok it's not bad this is set up that I
that I chose you ok so he's basically no
wait on wait wait wait ok ok h5 is the
positional move but what about g5 isn't
this like this is terrible h5 I will
sacrifice and he loses directly wish of
age 5
and while taking losses apiece and I'm
threatening h5 really wow h5 isn't this
complete destruction looks really
terrible maybe not but yeah come on i'm
playing this first and think about it
later yeah if for but i still don't
believe it can take here can take f2
maybe this is really playable a form i
didn't really consider the move too much
which is just the sign of my typical bed
calculation ok i will take that first I
mean it cannot really take on g3 I think
this looks really bad after Bishop e3
back so he has to take on c5 okay this
isn't as convincing as a thought I
thought I would be winning basically Wow
ok Georgie hmm but this isn't this just
good for me I don't understand any move
here funny check now this idea
yeah this okay this is this is
interesting this is interesting any
alternative to taking probably not it's
not something that I love to do but
probably have to is this is dangerous
compensation from black young dro cat
form now okay maybe I should have just
played h5 with this typical torture
position I don't know this is
interesting at least yeah okay it's not
it's not giving the check
I'm totally unsure you have to play
quick mousse and hope that is this okay
my idea is that here I mean maybe night
h6 is a month well night age six could
be okay I thought King takes pawn takes
26 is definitely good for me and night
moves are crazy i think i look crazy
it's beside night age 6 you should get
in queens g5 check i think check yeah
okay I have to go here bishop no not
working interesting he wants to play 94
maybe well it's a big problem that I
kind of a playbook g1
I want to go Queen to h4 is my idea but
yes it definitely ideas a good position
here anyway this is this at least very
dangerous now it's got some ponds
already looking for strong germanium
maybe I should have gone to e1 now
instead of g2 now kill you one that's
better yeah I can go King d2 then and I
can also ignore the rookie if you could
please repair foyer this is what I
should have done but ok this is this is
already history here f3m hard not to
take good or bad it's kind of forced
hmm jump it opens up his Bishop here
hmm that's a tempo Liam can pull loose
Andrew gave aid is coming
yeah I have to play move here cannot
wait all day it looks very dangerous
anyway I'm giving up the piece here for
the so that i get the g6 pawn it's
probably worse to losing but I mean I
don't think I could have defended well
okay I didn't see that one it's good of
course
mhm look so wacky but I g5 is good yeah
g5 is a good move now it wasn't it was
bad right here at least in a practical
game it was definitely bad and probably
also objectively my king is just too
weak this is just winning a half no move
no move well I have to go to e1 then
when there must be a clear advantage for
white black black is opening play was
was really really tired morning hey okay
come on not gonna kruky aid and so on
this is this is really really bad so
what do maybe just King you want maybe I
just have to go to e1 and that's it this
is this is simply unplayable I'm sorry
but so let's see what is best it takes
FG takes f night h5 is winning yeah ok
this is one way to do it getting this
and player for later Plus to buy stock
fish but what what about this is this
bad really I mean F for it is it is bad
in comparison I can also i mean this
this is just just all so clearly better
for why because he has to play g5 and
then is in this typical rotten position
where why does just yeah slowly
squeezing him to death but I thought I
should really end this game right away
and when g5 it is probably probably
right but this is better i'm now that is
it is better I mean this kind of
position is really the problem is i'm
just taking this and without the bishop
but what about is king
okay i can i can give you the best line
that there that that stock fish is given
here and show you this is this is really
funny yeah I have this square here will
Castle long and engine this is just King
hand okay but this is bad due to f4 at
least in comparison yes so take on g5
with the Queen and this is again
probably probably just winning right
kamia brookside King e1 and he can
resign I look at four I'm simply indeed
yet yeah I didn't understand the whole
thing at all that he has ruka for it
which is a pretty normal move but I just
I just played this far too quickly
basically instantly I was thinking that
ok well I win here with this this kind
of situation but Luke Air Force is
keeping the game on it's not winning but
the difference is that if i go here look
at a king he won then then he has no
loose whatsoever what is black doing now
threatening to take here and in his king
is in a terrible situation i can just
play king king over next the relatively
best is something something like this
yeah like here and this this i can
safely ignore i can just go here here
and and that's it my king is totally
safe this is the difference i never take
the rook now and the problem was that
after this i have to take it because he
threatens on g5 and this is of course
now opening up his queen this is maybe a
position where against the computer
Black is not in such great shape our
stock fishes just saying why it's
winning but it's not not easy in the
game in a practical game especially with
limited time very difficult to defend
the compy I wants to do this and now
wants to take on g6 yeah this was
probably not a great idea this h7 move
this is better okay an hour probably
also because I'm winning
I Addison yeah this looks this looks
quite convincing them indeed and now
this and queen edge fryer yeah this is
this is defending for white yeah i'm not
i'm not sure yet i mean the compass
giving me plus one point six probably
probably it is a win it still looks kind
of shaky the thing is that quite often
even with an exchange of it's not so
easy because this is such a fantastic
piece only five so have to be a half to
be cautious a little bit with the
evaluation but the compensating plus two
it's probably probably too NTM Bishop g4
and and f3 is also FF three wins and it
was it was becoming clear here that i
have no defense against the subject
young teenage former this is just
winning yeah yeahs mentioned when he
played the opening really atrociously
bad but after that he played it really
well this kind of stuff was good at can
care for was strong also the only move
yeah i mean there's nothing else that
you can do but this was this was really
a really bad decision at King g2 I mean
at the moment I had a little bit of time
I could just briefly think about and if
I spot look at four I just probably need
a couple of seconds to see the idea and
then I see that my king is in a problem
and if i go here it's really very
smoothly i just go here i'm safe with
the king and this is just just terrible
famine okay thanks for watching